Anna you could uh smell that elusive
Victory even yesterday against Nazi you
were so close but finally you got it in
today's game take us through the game
and your initial emotions after this
important
Victory um I didn't expect uh Kings
Indian it was came to me as a surprise I
was expected n and um I spent a lot of
time making decision in which line where
should I go and uh usually I'm playing
something different and I think I never
played this before uh I knew of course a
little bit about this line I Was
preparing my student and I was trying to
recall some lines and I spent a really
lot of time decided where should I go
yes and it was after this uh Knight to
H5 that it felt a little bit off because
of this bishop takes H5 and the
transition yes I think G5 she should
play G5 here right that's after Bishop
F4 G5 is the best move G5 and what was
was your plan yeah but still you
cannot uh I was not sure because like in
the beginning I was thinking about uh H3
Knight
A6 something F3 but I didn't like um so
maybe bishop E3 I was thinking maybe
bishop E3 or Bishop D2 to go yes because
after Bishop G3 I didn't like
Knight yes to give up yeah there's many
options Bishop G3 is the most logical
move move and after Knight A6 I was
thinking H3 Knight C5
F3 now I can go I didn't like Knight H5
Knight H5 and Knight F4 okay she will
have I will she will have a bad Pawn
structure but I think like your
initiative yes this this is bad for me
yeah yes yes yes so this was I didn't
like this position yes that's why I
would I would yes yes I would probably
come up with something else Knight H I
think after Knight H5 I have good
position but she couldn't like remember
on lines especially I never played this
line before and
uh yeah and you got to this position I'm
slightly better yes you started picking
up pawns and at the right moment you
sacrificed the exchange with Rook Bishop
takes D4 how did you ass I think
they like winning I have like three
points for exchange and yours are bad
it's like winning yeah yeah and I think
you were right about that she never got
back like here interest here was
interesting Qui please go ahead it's
interesting that if I play H3 here Rook
E4 Rook G5 uh King H6 and I don't like
win right away I have to play
H uh ah I okay then just King goes back
G6 yeah yeah it you're not winning
immediately for sure yes you can go H so
that's why I was yes H4 that's why I was
here thinking a little bit and play King
F3 this is winning right away yes yes
very nice King to F3 not here not here
yes King F3 and this is just winning
yeah and it was a surprise that she
didn't resign much earlier and like
checking how I can promote three
connected
pawns well you did manage to do so
congratulations on a good start for
this tournament for you and we'll see
you tomorrow our congratulations as well
we're going to